l'effervescence et l'agitation des
grands jours pour la première fois de
son histoire l'Hôtel de Ville de
Versailles se transforme en podium pour
un défilé de mode éco-responsable une
première également pour une partie des
mannequins et des créateurs pour qu'il
ait les dernières secondes avant le
défilé sont intenses
il est où Valentine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se créateur de bijoux d'accessoires
ou encore de vêtements au style variés
s'apprête à présenter leur création
devant plus de 400 personnes leur point
commun des pièces engagées pour limiter
l'impact de la mode sur l'environnement
moi mon parti pris c'est plutôt des
matières premières qui sont qui sont qui
viennent de fournisseurs qui a peu de
autour de Paris en tout cas proche j'ai
tout ce qui est boucleries c'est des
artisans qui fabriquent la boucle
fleurie sur Paris c'est plutôt un côté
responsable au niveau de la proximité
des matières et après la fabrication
l'objectif c'est de faire des sacs qui
durent dans le temps sur le travail bois
et cuir il y a deux on a j'ai deux types
de sacs j'ai ce modèle là ça c'est
l'insolent qui a un sac qui est assemblé
par une un système de pliage un peu
comme une origami avec du boulot sur le
côté dans une idée très épurée et à
l'inverse on peut aller vers un sac
comme ça qui est réalisé entièrement
avec des coutures faites à la main c'est
des coutures sellier traditionnelles de
maroquinerie qui sont faites à travers
le bois la chef d'orchestre de ce
défiler Alison Laurent fondatrice de la
marque Kentucky reigns
par ici et quand je vais faire mon petit
eech c'est parti pour une demi-heure de
chaude un défilé atypique mêlant danse
et musique un défilé doublement engagé
car en plus d'être écologique les
créateurs ont choisi l'inclusivité dans
le choix des mannequins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parmi les mannequins justement Cindy
fontaine une créatrice de bijoux
éco-responsable pour qu'il est important
de créer avec des matières déjà
existantes c'est hyper important parce
que de toute façon il y a tellement de
matières premières finalement il y a pas
besoin d'aller fabriquer à chaque fois
des matières premières tous ces bijoux
fantaisie qui sont cassés et qui dorment
dans justement nos tiroirs et dont on y
n'a plus aucune utilité nous on s'amuse
justement on faire des nouveaux bijoux
et qui plaisent encore donc pourquoi ne
pas continuer comme ça c'est hyper
important de réutiliser de réemployer
les matières premières le but de ce
défiler également sensibiliser le public
à l'évolution de l'industrie de la mode
vers plus de durabilité super beau une
super organisation les vêtements étaient
bien diverses enfin divers très joli
très bien mis en valeur par les
mannequins bah moi j'ai trouvé très
intéressant il y avait un
on voyait bien les univers des
différents créateurs Paris réussi pour
les créateurs accueillis par le public
sous un tonnerre d'applaudissements